on the cupboard this week Venezuela's at
the brink a tenth of the population have
fled partly because they're starving
medicines are running out inflation is
an estimated 1.7 million percent the
election last year was such a fast for
the opposition boycotted either the
despot Nicola Maduro Falls or he doesn't
in which case expect matters to get a
lot worse
in Latin America's worst government
country last week one Guido the leader
of the National Assembly in Venezuela
declared himself interim president
pending elections immediately mr. Guido
was recognized by all the important
democracies in the Americas apart from
Mexico Canada the United States Brazil
Argentina Colombia and we're going to
press hundreds of thousands of
Venezuelans are pouring onto the streets
demanding that Medeiros stepped down
he's wrecked the country he's wrecked
the economy he's tortured his opponents
and at least 80% of Venezuelans are
heartily sick of him and want him to
stand down
the government has always depended on
the Armed Forces and on armed vigilante
gangs to put down opposition with force
and often considerable bloodshed but
it's running out of money to pay the men
in uniform a major in the National Guard
only makes the equivalent of $15 a month
they've eat out their salaries by being
allowed to steal money or dominate
businesses there's even a general in
charge of toilet paper distribution the
United States ratcheted up the pressure
this week by saying that any oil that
Venezuela sells to the United States the
money will go to the legitimate
government ie the one controlled by Juan
Gweedore rather than maderos government
that's a huge deal for Venezuela as the
source of almost all its exports and
it's very difficult to sell Venezuelan
crude oil anywhere else by putting these
sanctions on Venezuelan oil the American
government is hoping to starve the
Majuro regime of the buns it needs to
oppress it
complicating matters is what one might
call the axis of despots particularly
Russia Vladimir Putin doesn't like to
see autocrats
fall and does like to cause trouble in
America's backyard it's been reported
that a group of Russian mercenaries have
been sent to protect nicolas maduro
whether that will be enough to protect a
regime that has almost no friends at
home and very few abroad remains to be
seen we think the world should recognize
one why does the legitimate president of
Venezuela because he is and offer
Nicolas Maduro safe passage out of the
country perhaps to a comfortable
retirement in Cuba once it's no longer
run by an incompetent tyrant the
prospect for Venezuela are actually
rather good within living memory it's
been a sophisticated liberal
middle-class democracy the knowledge of
how to build such a society is still
there in Venezuela and they could
rebuild it again very quickly